[Music]
foreign
hi there it's good to see you again
you do the fighting hi there it's good
[Music]
be safe all right
you do the fighting i'll do the forging
hi there it's good to see you
[Music]
goodbye
hi there it's good to see
i hope that can help
i will try
can you tell me what happened here
this thing of me
print
[Music]
uh
a blood trail
please don't be the girl
nobody
too old to be the man's daughter
the body is cold
drained of blood
i could have done this so quickly
[Applause]
discarded clothing
and another emaciated body
the vine was
feeding on the corpse
they're training this village of its
blood
why
someone help
please i can't open the door father
are you there
heard a noise
who's out there
alexa i'm going to get you out of there
i'm a friend your father he didn't
leave
no
alyssa
your father is dead you really did see
him
didn't you all right but stay
the camp is this way
follow me
uh
alyssa get back let me fight them
are you all right
no
no i'm okay you are not nothing
we will help the device have me
do not fear we will fight back these
traitors together
[Music]
no time to rest yet stranger more are
coming
abilities already
is that all of them
yes but remain alert we are close to
their den my rogues and i will continue
the pursuit
stop her
listen no
oh gods forgive me a cruel fate for one
so young
i am a crusader of zuckeroon
let me see it sadly
[Music]
ah
commander
lockery's flavi as for you outlander
considering you fought your way through
that village gladly
[Music]
take caution
the blood swan are not to be trifled
with
the rogues were outnumbered but fought
well
i will finish their fight
the faithful are rewarded
[Music]
right
feed the interloper to the bloodworms
let's not be too eager
friend
i beseech you
free me of these vines
i did not expect much kindness you're
welcome
they were torturing me kasha
yes he's lost a lot i've gotten this you
outlanders seemed may the great eye
watch over you
mistress
i've done as you asked
the blood of every man woman and child
in blackstone runs through your veins
yet it is not enough
i must be home once more
hasten your parents lest you lose my
favor
crush his new
pets the light burns within me
the abilities already
oh
i won't fail her i can't
this land has always belonged to her
she will ensure you remember those you
have forgotten
lockery escaped
kasha will need to know about this
you there
where is kasha oh she uh she left for
the battle camp a while ago had a druid
in turn head east through the woods to
find the camp but be careful
[Music]
yep
so
leave me alone you
monsters
so
[Music]
uh
yes
nobody
recycle room that abilities already
fury upon you not ready
[Music]
still recharging
uh
[Music]
you